[Musique]
nous sommes le 5 octobre 2016 bienvenue
pour cette nouvelle édition du 7 8 les
invités rencontres avec celles et ceux
qui font l'actualité dont le département
des yvelines est aujourd'hui vous
entendrez elle david douillet le patron
des républicains des yvelines il prépare
l'organisation de la primaire s'il
réaffirme sa neutralité ils n'hésitent
pas à venir défendre son candidat
nicolas sarkozy l'ancien président
toujours dans la tourmente olivier
guitare de l'association village
d'yveline en transition nous présentera
la nouvelle édition de la fête du vélo
son ambition rappeler que le vélo n'est
pas qu'un sport il permet aussi de
découvrir la richesse des paysages et
puis et kathleen senti steban nous
parlera de l'opération insolite qui va
voir le jour ce week end à maurepas le
mobilier urbain sera recouvert de
lainage pour l'automne
politique donc pour débuter et les
républicains qui viennent d'inaugurer
leur nouvelle permanence dans les
yvelines c'est à jouy en josas une
permanence afin de mieux préparer la
primaire de la droite et du centre qui
se déroulera en novembre nous avons
rencontré le président des républicains
des yvelines david douillet également
député de la 12e circonscription et
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france et
nous parle de ce rendez-vous mais
surtout de son soutien sans faille à
nicolas sarkozy c'est au micro
d'haussmann vendeurs des
supermamans seul et totalement
impartiales voilà
il est je ne tiendrai pas aucune
activité pour l'un ou pour l'autre voilà
c'est la permanence des républicains
voilà tous les candidats à la primaire
sont replica est celle ou celui qui
seront élues 27 novembre sera la
personne derrière laquelle tous les
africains vont se ranger pour gagner
cette présidentielle c'est très clair
donc ce message le dit dès aujourd'hui
le plus grave problème que nous
pourrions rencontrer au sein des
républicains
c'est la division c'est les plaies qui
n'arrivent pas à cicatriser donc il ne
faut pas occasionné de plaies c'est
absurde parlons vous deux quand même
votre choix qui est nicolas sarkozy il a
vécu une semaine difficile
oui bah comme il l'a dit à chantilly
lors de son meeting il faudra le curé
paix sans rentrer dans le détail ni sens
et diffamants
parce que c'est aujourd'hui mon milieu
la politique je peux vous assurer que ja
je suis pas un adepte de la théorie du
complot mais tout a été fait tout a été
fait dans l'opposition comme dans
certains partis de nos rangs certains
partisans de mort pour tuer nicolas
sarkozy pourquoi parce que c'est le
meilleur c'est clair c'est net on en a
les preuves
donc j'ose espérer que cet acharnement
se traduira dans la tête de ceux qui
soutiennent les républicains et des
citoyens des français comme un
acharnement injustifié juste parce que
c'est la vérité moi je suis devant vous
vous êtes liban tout le monde et qui
vend à partir du moment où on prend un
mot un groupe de mots dans une phrase ou
dans un contexte on peut faire ce qu'on
veut c'est sale c'est ça l'idée sauf que
certains prennent le clivage
comme une agression ce clivage qui en
fait pour certains du clivage maire
carette qui en réalité mais que la
vérité
parce que pour tout vous dire
je constate je suis pas le seul à
constater et des amis de gauche comme de
droite le constatait il ya
malheureusement des phénomènes de
communautarisme qui s'opère et c'est
qu'on le veuille ou non pour le rejette
ou non que les bobos parisiens on ne
s'en rende compte ou pas peu importe
mais je vous assure que ça existe je vis
à côté des mûrons je le vois tous les
jours malheureusement je dis
malheureusement que ce n'était pas comme
ça avant il faut pas que ce soit comme
ça j'ai rencontré un de mes amis qu'il
ya un footballeur
algérien et qui est franco algérien
habib national de haut niveau de très
haut niveau il me dit moi j'habite est
possible dans mon immeuble il y avait
des portugais gré des français y avait
des marocains des algériens des maliens
et à l'époque il ya trente ans mais
personne ne se pose la question qui le
monde vivait ensemble tout allait bien
et là quand je reviens là où je sais où
j'ai grandi c'est plus du tout la même
chose je me sens moi-même un étranger
problème il faut régler ce problème
village des yvelines en transition et
ben en transition s'associent pour la
fête du vélo qui est programmé ce 9
octobre bonsoir une vieille guitare vous
êtes membre de village divine en
transition va parler de ce rendez-vous
et puis plus globalement du travail que
vous menez avec ce réseau et et cette
association
tout d'abord la promenade parce que ce
sera une promenade qui se déroule le 9 9
octobre c'est en deux temps il ya la
promenade tout d'abord et puis un rallye
après comment s'organise cette journée
alors ça commence pour les plus motivés
par une balade le matin qui partira à
11h de
3.23 point de rendez vous
mary villiers saint frédéric l'allier
mairie de joueurs qu'on chartrain et le
parking du g20 à benne pour une balade
d'environ une heure pour rejoindre la
forêt de sainte apolline
neauphle-le-château ça fait combien de
kilomètres à peu près où ça fera un peu
moins de 10 ans se faisait elle aussi
pour les enfants russes et si les
parents veulent venir avec leurs enfants
alors quel est l'objectif un petit peu
de ce rendez vous avec la promenade du
matin puis le rallye l'après midi les
animations donc sur place on l'imaginé
du côté de la forêt de sainte apolline
alors l'objectif c'est vraiment de faire
un événement festif et familial et de
bas de rappeler que le vélo c'est pas
qu'un sport difficile
que c'est aussi voilà un moyen de de
découvrir ces les environs les endroits
où on habite est un moyen de se déplacer
surtout parce qu'elle est là la
sensibilisation vous voulez opéré elles
devraient le vrai leitmotiv un petit peu
de votre association cessé d'opérer
cette transition vers une nouvelle
société on parle des transports mais y'a
pas que les transports on ne viendra
peut-être après mais concernant les
transports vous mettez l'action réguler
l'accent pardon régulièrement avec ce
genre d'action alors on va globalement
les villes en transition donc nous ces
villages des villes en transition il ya
ben en transition et aussi saint quentin
en yvelines en transition
globalement l'idée c'est de rassembler
des citoyens pour pour essayer d'agir
localement
face au changement climatique se
préparer aux changements climatiques et
et agir aussi
face à la pénurie de ressources fossiles
qui s'annonce donc comment préparer
finalement un mode de vie plus sobres
mais également plus plus convivial plus
agréable y a pas que le vélo pour ça
qu'elles sont les docteurs vélo alors
dans le domaine des transports donc avec
ben en transition également nous allons
lancer une association pouces 10 blinky
établi un réseau d'auto stop organisé
dans les yvelines donc sur la base de
réseaux pouces qui existe déjà depuis
quelques années en midi pyrénées
actuellement on compte 16 communes
adhérentes et environ 300 inscrits donc
c'est vraiment le début donc ça c'est
pour les transports puis on fait aussi
dans le domaine de la réparation
réparation des objets dont coop fédérée
par café les gens se mettent ensemble
pour réparer des objets voilà on
participe au défi familles à énergie
positive avec la lettre de saint quentin
pour encourager aux éco gestes que la
bourse locale ou à leurs économies
d'énergie effectivement qui dispense des
conseils régulièrement est ce que c'est
une une opération des opérations qu'ils
prennent globalement ce que vous
constatez une hausse des inscriptions et
des différents participants sur les
opérations
oui oui ça un or ça se développe pas
aussi vite que le fait qu'on le
souhaiterait
damman
bon il ya eu un gros gros élan l'an
dernier avec la le phénomène comme 21
les mouvements alternatiba donc on a
fait notre propre alternative à 50 ans a
permis de rassembler d'élargir d'élargir
le cercle
voilà après il reste encore encore
beaucoup à faire pour pour faire changer
les mentalités essentiellement parce que
votre mouvement et est indépendant de
tout parti politique vous voulez positif
concret orientée vers les solutions
c'est ce que c'est ce que vous annoncez
dégagé de tout parti politique mais pour
autant il ya des élections qui arrivent
et on imagine vous souhaitez aussi faire
passer vos idées est ce que vous aller
interpeller les élus les candidats en
tout cas sur les prochaines élections je
pense aux législatives notamment puisque
c'est pour des actions concrètes de
proximité alors c'est vrai qu'on n'est
plus tourner vers les verts les citoyens
de
que vers les politiques c'est vrai que
notre action c'est plus de finalement
d'agir sur du concret faire en sorte que
les que les gens par la pratique
par la pratique du vélo par la pratique
de la la réparation etc prennent
conscience d'un certain nombre de
phénomènes après voilà on informe aussi
sur
sur les
sur les conséquences du changement
climatique etc et on travaille aussi
avec les élus pour
notamment pour la mise en place de
réseaux d'auto stop organisé ça se fait
on ça se fait avec les collectivités
locales et puis ont interpellé les élus
par rapport
aux infrastructures pour le vélo et
c'est parce que justement pour se
déplacer plus à vélo pour laisser sa
voiture au garage il faut aussi des
pistes cyclables est ce que concrètement
sur le secteur il y en a assez on en a
vu fleurir ces même si c'est pas le
terme ces dernières années mais est-ce
que c'est suffisant alors sur saint
quentin en yvelines s'est vraiment bien
équipé dans l'est dans les zones plus
rurales c'est déjà un petit peu plus un
peu plus difficile
il ya encore pas mal de travail
chez nous en plus il ya du relief donc
on fait aussi la promotion du vélo
électrique parce que construit qu'en
plus de mal c'est vrai que le vélo
électrique est une est une bonne
solution et puis le problème des
parkings de gare voilà donc le l'enjeu
c'est aussi le sens de deux ballons
savons que les politiques prennent
conscience de finalement de tous les
gains pour la société que peut avoir
une augmentation de la pratique du vélo
en termes d'économies sur la santé mais
même si sur les infrastructures parce
que une place de voitures libérer ces
huit places de vélo nous et c'est le
message que vous allez faire passer on
imagine aussi lors de cette opération du
9 octobre cette fête du vélo qui sera
avant tout festive mais qui sera aussi
l'occasion de dispenser votre message le
rendez-vous le pour les points de départ
c'est à partir de quelle heure donc les
rendez vous sont à 11 heures pour les 3
points de départ ensuite donc un midi
donc on fait pique nique en forêt de
sainte apolline et à 13h30 c'est le
départ du rallye donc à 2 2 circuits
sportif et familial et il est fortement
conseillé de s'inscrire de s'inscrire
l'adresse internet on va la donner
l'adresse mail cv y transition tout
attaché y transition @ laposte.net pour
vous inscrire ce qui facilitera
l'organisation pour le lendemain merci à
vous d'être venu nous parler de cette
initiative il est question à présent de
tricot le tricot qui s'invite en centre
ville dans le centre-ville de maurepas
depuis cette semaine les habitants ont
pu découvrir le yarn bombing c'est du
tricot graffitis sur le mobilier urbain
de la ville vous allez voir que c'est
une première pour cette commune les
bancs les arbres ou encore les poteaux
sont décorés avec de la laine on écoute
la directrice de la boutique à la trique
au tec qui a mis en place cet événement
c'est au micro de camille lambert
human being ou tricot graffitis
ça consiste à utiliser des restes de
laine des restes de pelote quand on a
fini un pull des fois il nous reste un
peu de laine et on tricote pour le
mobilier urbain ce qui permet de faire
de l'art urbain en fait ça donne une
deuxième vie à la laine et ensuite j'ai
contacté la société le relais qui
recycle les textiles notamment et du
coup la laine qui va encore la recycler
pour faire des isolants donc ça donnera
une troisième but à l'aller même ce père
ça débute maintenant tout sera prêt
samedi et ça reste un mois en centre
ville de maurepas l'objectif c'est de
faire découvrir c'est aussi de donner de
la joie et de la bonne humeur avec des
couleurs et de se réapproprier un petit
peu la ville en décorant le mobilier
urbain on parle aujourd'hui slick aux
thérapies justement c'est vraiment
quelque chose de relaxant et gratifiant
si le pouvoir faire des choses soi-même
il ya 50 kg qui ont été pris côté ça
représente à peu près 1000 pelote tout
soit sont que des restes de dons de dons
aussi de bergère de france 2 y avoir 54
mobilier urbain quand je dis mobilier
urbain c'est ben candélabres poubelle
mais j'ai pas compté les arbres il doit
y en avoir une vingtaine donc j'ai
sollicité la mairie pour avoir
l'autorisation luxe et du mobilier
urbain
ne touche pas comme ça
donc ils ont tout de suite été emballé
et ils m'ont donné l'autorisation de le
faire ils ont du coup communiquer dessus
pour inviter les habitants de maurepas à
participer à l'opération puisque c'est
quelque chose qui est totalement gratuit
moi j'avais mis à disposition et dont
glen à la boutique en expliquant un peu
ce qu'on pouvait faire et je donnais des
pelote pour tricoter pour ça il ya à peu
près 70 personnes qui ont participé
dont du coup le cpm donc les
cyclotouristes de mort pas la maison de
retraite repos tél l'association mort
par entraide et tous les habitants qui
étaient intéressés selon mes clientes de
l'atelier était très emballé mais
on présente qu'une quinzaine de
personnes à l'atelier donc je
m'attendais vraiment pas ce qui est
autant de participants on espère le
refaire tous les ans après c'est
beaucoup de travail ça fait quatre mois
qu'on travaille dessus mais cela dit vu
le résultat
je pense que ça ça vaut ce que ça vaut
le détour ça vaut le détour hier c'est
en tout cas la fin de cette édition
demain vous saurez tout sur le nouveau
festival de bd de buc nouvelle édition à
venir dès ce week end excellente soirée
et à très bientôt sur notre antenne
[Musique]